my uh reasoning for being so sure about
that was that UPS cannot afford to be
offline because FedEx will take all
their business
and so they're going to do a deal that's
what I that's what I said and you had
other information about it yeah and you
said what I don't know I said that uh if
if they were to go on strike I thought
that it would be very very brief and
that their fund each major Union like
that has a fund that is set aside
essentially a rainy day fund to pay
their members because Unions would lose
all power if in Striking they hurt their
actual members so I said I think you've
got enough money set aside for about
three months I believe is what I saw in
the news and so I assured her that I
think you're going to be fine I don't
think it'll go anywhere near that long
and then I said it's like the people in
the news that try to scare us about the
federal debt ceiling and I don't care if
it's Republicans in power or dims in
power every time this happens they
always get together at the last minute
or keep raising them down yeah no you're
not they're never going to do that so
it's don't be scared there's no reason
to be scared and by the way it settled
yesterday boy the crowd wolf yeah so
yeah you're right UPS settled yesterday
and the reason we bring this up is we
were both right that's right it's rare
we've both been married a long time so
folks we needed a moment to gloat
we get to do it here on the air but
maybe not at home not at home at all we
were right we were right that's right we
were right yeah so there's a lot of
basic Common Sense observation that
leads to that yeah absolutely all right
Victoria's starting today off in
Colorado Springs hi Victoria how are you
hi great thank you thank you so much for
taking my call sure Ken what's up
I just had a question my husband and I
are 32 and 31 we have four young kids
with a fifth on the way
um we became debt free thanks to your
teaching four years ago
um and I'm wondering how you recommend
we talk to my in-laws about their
appointments for retirement
uh uh how long you been married no
we'll be married uh 10 years and I know
as a daughter-in-law that's not my
my husband's gonna take the lead on that
um no he's going to do it you're not
gonna take a lead on it you're not
saying a word
okay not if you want this to go well I
mean no yeah no no no I'm just making
this call on behalf of him he's at work
right now okay all right and why is he
concerned about their retirement
um so they're about 60. it's my mother
my husband's mom and his stepdad
um they've always struggled financially
and have nothing saved for retirement
um and at this point we're concerned
that we're the backup plan
why are you the backup plan
beginning not to work for a year because
she
felt she deserved a break so she was
living on unemployment no but why does
that make you the backup plan
um so my husband is better off than his
siblings
um why does that make you the backup
plan
um we're afraid that we are so we
so we need to talk why what we're
getting at is have they said to you all
have they intimated or come right out
and said hey we're planning to live with
you guys or is this just a fear um
there's just a general sense of
entitlement there
um and might I suggest that your husband
feels obligated that you guys think
you're the backup plan because he is
planning to do it if they don't get it
figured out and that's an unnecessary
obligation is that possible
yeah yeah I think so
yeah you don't like that your
mother-in-law is lazy and you don't want
to take care of her
I'm sorry yeah okay I I got that I'm
okay with that
um but the uh um so yeah I think I for
sure uh for sure he if anybody talks to
him at all it needs to be him but he
needs to have a real clear uh idea of
what what his goal is with his
conversation uh if he thinks one
conversation is going to cause them to
suddenly become diligent savers
I think that conversation is going to
fail
if he's just trying to discover where
they stand
so he can decide and you can decide what
level you want to participate in their
help later then you probably could get
that going but or if he wants to
establish a boundary he could probably
get that done and say you know Mom and
Dad
um just want you all to know uh we're
not your backup plan and you can say
that a lot of different ways but he can
deliver that message that's an okay
conversation that could be successful
moderately probably not going to work
real well but you could try it and at
least that's a something a single
conversation could accomplish
is just letting them know you know we're
we will be your cheerleaders and I'll
coach you and help you on handling your
money but we're not going to be the ones
taking care of you so we need to go and
establish that and given that if how can
I help you guys or would you let me help
you uh with some input and you know help
you dial in your plan a little bit and
you know just be of assistance but
they're not asking for help
of any kind uh they're not asking for
instruction and they're not asking for
money right now so um you know you you
might be able to establish a boundary or
beginning establish a boundary you might
be able to get the some encouragement
and some coaching involved that would be
nice that'd be a wonderful thing for a
son to do for his parents for his mom
and stepdad
um but uh but you're not going to have a
single conversation that solves her uh
two decade pattern of not liking to work
much
that's a single conversation and gonna
do that that's correct and I say you're
gonna be disappointed because there's
not you there's not multiple
conversations coming from her son are
not going to make her go to work
okay that was her dad that had to do
that one and then we're way past that
that ship has sailed so
um and always keep in mind uh folk when
you're talking to your mom and dad uh
you are facing the powdered butt
syndrome
once someone has powdered your butt they
don't really want your opinion
about money or sex no input help no
inputs helpful there so
um
I mean a lot of people's parents never
talked about sex and never talked about
money and everybody was surprised later
when they found out they had both
this is the Ramsay show
[Music]
[Applause]
if you're like most people your home is
your most valuable asset and when you
want to make improvements it can feel
like everything costs too much or takes
too long but something as simple as
custom window coverings from blinds.com
can completely change your space and add
value to your home we've recommended
blinds.com for over a decade so you know
you can trust them from blinds drapes
and shutters to motorized Shades they
make it easy and affordable to upgrade
your entire home and their team is ready
to help with everything from design
consultation to measuring and
installation plus there are never any
misleading quotes or hidden fees ever
things back by their
watch and guarantee and
hands-free see whyblinds.com is the
number one online retailer of custom
window coverings go to blinds.com now
and save 45 off selected products visit
blinds.com today for more info
foreign
[Music]
sponsored by neighborly your hub for
Home Services after fires or floods
their rainbow restoration Pros offer
homeowners trusted full-service
restoration expertise like mold
remediation carpet cleaning odor removal
and more visit neighborly.com today to
find rainbow restoration services in
your area today's question comes from
Allen in Pennsylvania some legislators
in my state are introducing a bill to do
a study on universal basic income at
this point it's just a proposal to do a
study but I was curious what your
thoughts are on the government providing
low-income people with a monthly stipend
I know other parts of the world have
introduced forms of it to varying
degrees of success
uh okay I'm not a fan of any type of
universal basic income for a variety of
reasons I'm gonna try to keep this short
uh first and foremost it does not create
incentive it does not allow someone to
see the value of showing up and putting
in some work and we know from human
behavior and we saw this in the United
States it's why we're in the
inflationary period that we're in
when we give out more money and
unemployment benefits were increased and
extended people spent the money people
don't save the money people need Dignity
of work to get up go do something get
paid and watch themselves continue to
make progress and the argument for
people that are pro stipend and I'm
seeing this all over the place in the
United States being tested in multiple
cities right now and it is a social
entitlement an entitlement if you look
at the word in the dictionary unless you
do it on your own it does not create
incentive it actually de-incentivizes
people and they end up misusing it so I
for that reason I'm not a fan of it at
all it's also a slippery slope to a
universal income across the board which
we see in socialistic countries like
Venezuela Cuba and more go do your
homework on how that has worked out yeah
generally speaking if you study history
communism has failed
for the little man to get ahead
capitalism and its current form today
is not perfect but it is by far in human
history all of human history at this
moment in time in the United States of
America the little man has a better
chance of getting ahead in becoming
somebody than he has in any other
government situation in any other
economic system in human history
uh this is straight out of the Karl Marx
Playbook
this is not out of the Adam Smith
Playbook let me help you with that Karl
Marx father of Communism Adam Smith
wrote the Tome that we were all required
to read on capitalism if we took
economics so my friend art Laffer one of
the leading economists in the world says
that if you pay people to not work
please expect them to not work
it's pretty deep yeah it's deep and true
and here's the thing so if if I thought
with my 40 years plus in the financial
world that this was hopeful to people
I would be for it even though I am a
staunch capitalist
just set me on fire and I burn
capitalism I mean it does I believe in
it to the core of my being
and if you don't like that that's okay
go start your own show this is mine and
so
uh uh this is what we do and so if I
honestly thought that if you were
struggling financially if you came up in
a a family in a socio-economic setting
on a lower rung of the ladder your best
shot at life of having a high quality
life was a universal income I would say
go it for it but I don't think it is as
a matter of fact my all of my experience
and all of the data we have at Ramsey
indicates that your best quality of life
is when your character is increased with
Grit
discipline calluses the ability to
overcome obstacles gives you much more
joy than the dull
hum of communism
it puts you to sleep and if the welfare
system worked people would be sprinting
out of these government-funded ghettos
into a Wonderful Life and instead
they've set up camp there generationally
and it's not good for you it's not it's
not you're you have no compassion I've I
have more compassion than you do if you
believe in this crap because it's not
good for you it's not good for someone
so I always think you know
the people that think capitalism doesn't
work are the ones that grew up here and
were trained by a tenured professor who
believes in uh oxy who believes in Karl
Marx more than he does Adam Smith and
they were taught by some idiot college
professor that this stuff actually works
well it works in Sweden let's just keep
in mind here Sweden the entire
population of Sweden the entire gross
domestic product output of Sweden is way
smaller than Dallas
okay so you can't really extrapolate
that type that size of an economy to the
size of an economy like ours and say
something works so that's just bonehead
asinine analysis
okay so you just that that's just crap
now
what does work is this
incentive what does work is a belief
that if I leave the cave kill something
and drag it home I get to keep it and
the government won't take it from me
that I had a young guy working for us
remember when social media first started
many years ago and we're all start we
learned this new term SEO yeah and he
was a young Tech Guy and uh he was from
Czechoslovakia any of this fabulous
American accent but with that Slavic
accent right or American he spoke
English but with that Slavic accent I
wish I could do it Hillbilly Slavic
would be awesome but I can't do it so
anyway Milan was his name and Milan left
to go get his master's degree he was 25
years old went to go get he he I love
Ramsay I love Ramsay but I'm gonna go
get my Master's Degree that's my best my
best invitation it's not pretty good
yeah pretty good and he he I said how
are you going to pay for it I don't know
but I'm gonna figure it out this is
America yeah
so he goes the the the the cost of the
Master's Degree for the first uh
semester was four thousand dollars
he goes to a garage sale
three days after he quit here
and the guy at the garage sale was a
Nike salesman
and he had a whole garage full of last
year's Nike's shoes samples that he used
to go to the stores to make the sale he
used to go to the vendors to make the
sales
so Milan buys the entire garage of last
year's Nikes
for 15 dollars
he said my whole back seat was full my
whole trunk was full I filled up the
passenger side love that he goes I put
them on eBay he said Dave in 48 hours I
got the money to go to school what a
country what a country
you don't get that with a universal
stupid but communism stipend yeah uh you
don't get that right you know you go you
know the the number of people nowadays
going to garage sales buying used
clothing for 10 cents selling it on eBay
for a buck 60 and making ten thousand
dollars a month doing this in mass is
unbelievable the first guy that ever
made a million dollars on eBay was
buying used golf clubs from people that
gave up on their horrible golf game
polished them up flipped them on eBay
yeah you don't get that if you're
sitting on your welfare check here's one
for you I interviewed a couple recently
on my show who now making over a million
dollars a year on their YouTube channel
teaching people how they were successful
at flea market flipping so they they
were making about 300 Grand a year just
on flea market flipping then they
started making videos of how they do it
and now they're making over a million
dollars that is individualism which by
the way is the opposite of Communism
Community communal is the root word and
they twist it America works because it
allows people the freedom to be who they
want to be I know a guy that was so
stupid that he filed bankruptcy because
he was so bad at handling money and he's
made millions of dollars teaching people
to live yeah right that's right yeah
what a country oh my gosh
I can't wait for the video that people
are gonna cut up a view with this new
accent I think it's gonna be huge it's
horrible it's horrible I wish it was
good because it was so bad it's not bad
oh you can't detect any East Tennessee
in that at all no Middle Tennessee no
Tennessee anywhere hillbilly Slavic
there leave it at that it's a whole new
it's a whole new dialect I just invented
it today I'll probably make money on
that too what a concert yeah this is the
Ramsey Show
[Music]
oh
it's a competitive home buying Market
but there's a way you can get an edge
Churchill Mortgage works with you to
understand your budget and your goals
and the Churchill Mortgage home buyer
Edge offers you fast pre-approval and a
secured interest rate plus Churchill has
bumped up their seller guarantee to ten
thousand dollars giving your offer the
best chance of being accepted and
helping you win in today's market go to
churchillmortgage.com today to learn
more
[Music]
foreign
[Applause]
[Music]
Coleman Ramsey personality is my co-host
today Marcy is with us Marcy is in
Oklahoma City hi Marcy how are you
hi Dave I'm doing good thanks for taking
my call sure what's up
so um I was calling to ask about life
insurance now my husband and I have been
married for 15 years
and he is 50 years old and I'm 36 but we
haven't really discussed life insurance
see what kinds of policies or for how
much just to protect us for the future
and to protect our assets
okay
well A good rule of thumb is and we're
going to start with that and then we'll
back into your particular situation
is a 15 to a 20-year level term
insurance policy that is about 10 to 12
times his income on him 10 to 12 times
your income on you that will replace the
income that is lost
so if you make fifty thousand dollars a
year that'd be 500 600 000 if he dies
you put 600 000 in an investment if it
makes ten percent that's sixty thousand
he was making fifty
you you've replaced his income so that's
the Baseline for for discussing this
okay
um then we put you on the baby steps
plan and we get you out of debt
and then we start saving for retirement
so as your retirement increases and your
debt decreases and your kids grow up
your need for life insurance begins to
go away
so for instance I have no debt several
hundred I have no debt several hundred
million dollars in real estate and my
kids are all grown and gone and
self-sufficient so if I die without any
life insurance Miss Sharon's gonna be
just fine
so I have become self-insured by
Building Wealth and staying out of debt
we've been able to um we don't have any
debt good and we have been able to build
our our wealth uh P makes about what how
much NASDAQ do you have
um we have a portfolio that is about
um 800 850 000 depending on the uh and
what does she mean
he makes about 150 000 a year okay and
do you have any children
uh he has one son but his son's older
okay but the two of you have no children
no okay and do you do you earn an income
I don't I stay at home okay cool all
right all right so if you want to
replace his hundred and fifty thousand
Let's Pretend his 800 would create 80.
leaves a deficit of 70.
okay 10 times that would be seven
hundred thousand
okay all right and uh the faster your is
your home paid off
yeah our homes paid off we don't have
any it's worth 260. you stay in it if he
dies
um nope okay no because I'd probably
want to move home okay yeah okay the
hesitation told me yeah okay all right
cool yeah and if you moved home if you
spent less than 260 that'd give you more
to live on so you're probably okay
because the truthful story is I mean
without any insurance the truthful story
is if he passes away it'd be horrible
and tragic yeah uh but you're gonna have
eight hundred thousand plus 260 from the
sale of a house You're Gonna Be A
Millionaire matter of fact you're a
millionaires now
okay okay and so you and you're 36 years
old you're probably gonna go have a a a
a a life after this
that probably involves creating some
income
right so you're you're you know you're
probably self-insured in actuality today
but if you wanted to shore it up and put
a half million on him that'd be fine
okay you're not creating an income if
you pass away he doesn't need to replace
the income that you're creating since
there isn't any so we don't need to
insure you and you're not playing Mary
Poppins to three kids and he's got to
hire people to take care of if he to
keep working if you pass away so again
we don't need to insure you at all he's
just a millionaire if you passed away
making 150 a year
and again what we're reducing a very
tragic horrible heart-wrenching
situation to a series of math numbers so
that's pretty dead gum cold but that's
the way it works out right
well
um just to make sure that you know we're
both protected or
you're protected you got 800 Grand
okay I mean that's pretty that's a lot
of protection and the truth is in in
seven years if that is invested in good
mutual funds that 800 will be 1.6
so you don't need a 15-year what I would
do if you really just want super
safeties I pick up a half a million on
him on a five-year policy won't cost
that much if he's healthy if he's not
fat and he doesn't smoke
that won't cost you no you're very
healthy okay I won't cost a lot then at
50. okay I mean I can buy it at 62. I'm
slightly overweight but I still qualify
and and I don't smoke so these are the
two things that kill you on life
insurance no pun intended and so um but
yeah if he does that you pick up a half
million five-year policy go to Xander
insurance and price that out and that'll
you know probably won't cost you much
and it'll give you a little peace of
mind but when you look up five years
from now don't renew that stupid policy
because you're going to be worth 2
million two and a half million dollars
at that point and if he dies you're
gonna be just fine just like Miss Sharon
is
and by the way she has completely
planned for me to die first Ken yeah
yeah I don't understand how our estate
plan is sure that I am dying first but
uh she's in much better shape than I am
I think it's an evil plot you think so I
think it could be I think she has a
hunch I understand I don't know is she
gonna travel the world Isis she's a very
social person he'll never see her again
sure it should be the one of those old
women that lives on a cruise ship I
think so she's very social walking fast
walking fast around the cruise ship she
will that's her that'll be her with some
of her friends
and if they weren't her friend before
the walk after the walk they're her
friend yeah so there you go true my
friend my friend so yeah I I think
that's probably what the way this is
going to go down so apparently our
entire state plan is planned around that
so if I was a betting man I would
probably put the chips on Sharon 75 of
the ladies husbands are the ladies that
live their husbands yeah and
statistically for whatever reason yeah
but I really think it's an evil plot I'm
I'm not sure Ryan is in Minnesota hey
Ryan what's up
hey Dave Hagen thank you for taking my
call sure how can we help
so um I was just calling question mostly
for Mr Coleman here um so I've read uh
proximity principle paycheck to purpose
did the click get clear assessments and
uh kind of was positioning myself for
um kind of the next step in my role
which I've been in for nine years uh
that role would just more so be a
supervisory position
um my company uh you know is is
splitting off and some of the
supervisory positions were going to
become available and as the split off
has happened time came for the
positions to be uh fulfilled and instead
of interviews they did appointments and
I was not one of those so kind of my
question is
um just kind of where you know your your
fantastic uh books of the top lead me
twice as I like project management and
kind of more teaching so do I stick with
the company wait for another opportunity
or do I pursue kind of project
management certificates or MBA with that
in cash of course uh well I would stay
if you're pursuing project management
stay in your current company and you're
going to get that certification and
training on the side you don't need to
go to school to get a project management
degree there are some very very clear
skills and you can get certifications in
fact we have a course at Ramsey uh led
by me and our chief technology officer
Brendan wojko that a lot of people have
taken and used uh to get hired so in
that case I would stay put if I'm going
to project management route I would not
pursue the MBA unless the MBA was
something that was required by a certain
company or a particular type of a job in
an industry where it may not be said
that it's required but it's pretty much
a cultural thing that you've got to do
other than that my friend you know where
you want to go I think you wanted to be
in leadership you certainly like the
instruction side of leadership it sounds
like with the teaching side of things
uh but I'd stay put get qualified while
I'm where I am look for an opportunity
and then move on but I'd stay put I
wouldn't go to school
this is the Ramsey Show
[Music]
foreign
[Applause]
[Music]
Coleman Ramsay personality is my co-host
today thank you for joining us open
phones at triple eight eight two five
five two two five Jessica is in San
Francisco hi Jessica how are you
question how are you better than I
deserve what's up
I have a question for you I'm a net
worth millionaire good for you and
um thank you I
would like to retire early and I'm not
sure if I'm funneling my money correctly
into the IRA versus The Brokerage
um because I've been paying down the
house aggressively
um so I'd like to get your input on how
I can channel that money to retire
around the age of 55. okay
so let me get under the motivation for
just a second uh because it does enter
into the answer
um
when I hear retire early
uh it can mean one of two things it
could mean I want to be wealthy enough
to retire early
or it could mean I hate my job and
that's the soonest I can see a way to
get out
to retire early because I love my job
but I want to have the option there we
go okay so instead of retire early I
want to be able to
okay I want to be able I want to be more
financially independent than I am now
and keep may keep doing what I love
because that's my case okay I don't I
haven't needed to work for a long long
time financially but I work because I
love what I do I'm having a blast I had
to run me out of here with a stick you
know what I'm saying okay so anyway
uh and I just like winning and we win a
lot at Ramsay so that's fun too uh all
right so if you want to have access to
enough income that is not penalized
you're going to have to have what we
always call Bridge accounts accounts
that are not in retirement accounts to
be able to access them before 59 and a
half a large portion of wealth but I I
would think getting your home paid off
particularly in the San Francisco Market
would be a big part of this as well and
so how much you said you're a net worth
millionaire give me a little breakdown
on that how's that categorized
um my net worth is just under about 1.7
okay my mortgage is currently 160 left
and your house is worthwhile
about 1.5 okay so the house is almost
paid off good
and uh how much is it and so that that's
uh 1.4 of the 1.7 right so you got 300K
in retirement
about
174 in IRAs 74 isn't a Roth the rest is
in traditional
brokerage I have about
152 yeah savings I have about 45 I want
to throw a chunk of that and your
household in your income must be
ridiculous what is it
uh
it's anywhere between
185 to 200. really yeah do you you have
piled up some oh you got this huge
equity in this house but you've done a
great job that you inherit any did you
inherit this house
I inherited about 500 000 which helped
with the down payment okay all right
that that explains it okay well you're
doing extremely well I was I was kind of
waiting on 700 000 income with these
numbers but the inheritance offsets that
so I get it okay good you're doing a
great job you're doing a great job so
you're at baby step what we call four
five six and I'd be putting 15 of my
income away into retirement if you want
to put some of that in uh brokerage
meaning in mutual funds but not in
retirement
uh that's okay but 15 of your income
needs to go towards mutual funds some in
retirement accounts some in uh and
everything else goes towards the house
until the house was paid off once the
house is paid off I'm going to put 15
percent into retirement and any other
money I can scrape together over into
bridge and you're gonna be just fine
you're going to plenty of money
what I'm doing
you a Roth IRA and then 500 into
brokerage I don't know if that sets me
up in the right place no you're gonna do
more than that
yeah you might you make you make 195
Grand 15 30 000 a year that's uh well no
that's probably pretty close 2500 bucks
a month that's what we're dealing with
so
um put more into the brokerage yeah like
300 more into the program that's fine
yeah something like that and then and
then make sure you're just any other
money you can scrape together let's
clear that 160. because if you clear
that 160
um you're gonna have a huge asset there
that you can do a lot of different
things with but the other thing is you
got rid of your most expensive line item
in your budget which is your uh housing
okay right and that house is going to
continue it's going to continue to go up
and uh up in value regardless of the
problems that San Francisco has you're
going to still see increases in value
there and the I want to pay the house
off in like three years good that's a
that's a good plan okay so you're gonna
be 40 with a paid for house and then
we're just going to load up you know
we're gonna put 15 into retirement
regular retirement 401K Roth IRAs and
we're going to put the rest of it over
into mutual funds and and if those
accounts double every seven years you're
going to be in really great shape at 55.
they will double every seven years plus
what you put in I'm sorry
you think I'm on track oh you're
definitely on track and you're doing a
great job congratulations you're amazing
wow yeah wow a lot of hustle and I want
people to hear that yes they had the
inheritance which allowed them to do the
big down payment but just the discipline
to knock that out and to be sitting on a
home worth that much money I mean that
is a game changer and you can do it on
that kind of income yeah but they
sacrifice I mean they've worked hard
she's in one of the most expensive real
estate markets in the world correct and
um you know and took advantage of that
uh but didn't overdo it that's right
didn't go well it's San Francisco I have
to buy five million no you don't
um she's in a million and a half which
is modest yeah what would you say that
is that's modest 2200 squares no no not
even not even that big okay depends on
where it's located sure sure but I mean
it's um yeah it's not huge this is not a
man she's not living in a mansion and
she's a millionaire at 37. yeah let's
just keep this in mind well done and I
also love that what you asked who a lot
of new people coming all the time I love
how you qualified why the early
retirement here's a woman who loves her
work she said mentally I can't see
myself quitting but what I heard from
that is it gives her options she may not
work for that particular company but the
type of work when you are 55 and and
able to walk away it's not that you walk
away from work it's that you may walk
into something completely different and
that we're not we're not made to just
shut down yeah and just Coast I thought
that was interesting I love how you
frame that as the motive we talked about
uh Jaden I talked about it earlier in
the week on this show
um the discussing the fire movement this
thing and early in my career a lot of
people were doing stuff like
teaching people to be financially
independent
and um that's a
um
that's a scary phrase yeah that's a
scary phrase I want to retire early
and do what right you know that's a
scary phrase okay so uh in her case she
doesn't she wants to have the wealth and
so number one you're never going to the
the more financial you have the less
independent you are you're more
dependent crap the more stuff you own
the more repairman you have to know okay
so we dealt with all that the other day
on the air and so but the retirement
thing is the same way having the money
to retire is one thing but what you said
is perfect it gives you lots of options
and here's the weird thing
people that don't have to work will get
joy from a job that they hate
that they might have hated if they had
to work really true that's absolutely
right because you feel stuck that's
correct and uh so our our career field
that's right or whatever else and it's
like I'm doing this because I want to
and therefore I like what I'm doing and
you know it's not drudgery real quick
for those uh the fire movement stands
for financial independent retire early
and Dave the guy who's considered the
founder of the movement I share this on
the Ken Coleman show about six weeks ago
he's now going back to work uh he
thought he had enough and now he's
panicking do I have enough to keep
staying and he's like I actually miss
work so here's a guy who over who who
thinks he miscalculated number one but
then he said I just miss showing up
every day and doing something that I
enjoy so that guy is back in the
workforce and you know again work that
has meaning where you're where you're
lifting someone's life whether you're
fixing their transmission or their
budget I don't care you're lifting
someone's life you're being of
assistance to other human humans that's
work that has meaning it's Man's Search
for meaning Victor Frankel so there you
go this is the Ramsay show
foreign
hey folks Ken Coleman here did you know
the Ramsay show is one of the most
popular podcasts in the world it's your
daily dose of advice on life and money
check out all of our shows from the
Ramsay Network wherever you listen to
podcasts
[Music]
live from the headquarters of Ramsey
Solutions broadcasting from the PODS
moving and storage Studios it's the
Ramsay show where we help people build
wealth do work that they love and create
actual amazing relationships kid Coleman
of the Ken Coleman show and the number
one best-selling book paycheck to
purpose the Ramsey personality on career
and jobs expert is my co-host today you
got career and jobs questions he's here
for you and we'll talk to you and we'll
talk to you about your life whatever you
want to talk about phone number triple
eight eight two five five two two five
Adam is in Salt Lake City hey Adam
what's up
hi Dave hi Ken thank you so much for
having me on the show sure what's up
um I have a question I'm trying to get a
few thoughts organized so I have a house
that is rented in a different state with
a mortgage of 216
000 currently and then I have my primary
residence in Salt Lake City which I
bought the last year and I'm trying to
decide whether I should keep both or
sell the rented uh property and then uh
the other part of the question I'm
trying to decide is I don't want to stay
in the primary residence for longer than
say two or three years because I would
like to ultimately buy a land and build
a house so I'm just trying to figure out
what would be the best option and then
start thinking about how to get there in
the next few years that's fun what do
you make
one hundred and three thousand good for
you girls and how old are you
I'm 32. good for you well done okay
the way we answer questions around here
Adam is based on uh what I know
uh what would I do if I was trying to
build wealth the fastest right way
uh what would I do if I woke up in your
shoes and that's how I think about these
things when someone calls here on the
show okay
and I know a lot about real estate I've
been owning real estate and managing
real estate and dealing with landlord
and tenant issues most of my adult life
and so and I love real estate I hate
long-distance landlording
it's a it's a recipe for failure and so
and I love being debt free all of those
things lead me to sell the rental house
and pay off your personal residence and
then use the fact that you make a lot of
money and you have no payments at that
point to pile up cash in a good
investment to pay cash for uh your
upgrade on this build that you're going
to do and then pay cash for your other
rental properties if you want to buy
some more investment properties later
but um that that advice is not popular
on tick tock
but I'm not running a Tick-Tock poll I'm
telling you based on a 40-year career of
helping people become millionaires what
I am pretty sure is that what I am very
sure is the best route for you to do the
same to become a millionaire and so I'm
not I'm not trying to run a popularity
contest here I'm just right there's a
difference
and so that's what we would tell you to
do well I think what we want to point
out here is that what you just said
isn't going to happen overnight and
that's why these schemes and The Tick
Tock videos are so popular because it
promises something that just quite
frankly isn't true and has tremendous
risk to it the get rich quick idea
versus what you just told our friend
here Adam uh Adam is going to be very
wealthy yeah and he's also going to be
secure and sleep well at night
absolutely and he's obviously a sharp
young guy very sharp you know very cool
and he's not at the end of his earning
potential either you got the feeling of
32 he's already making a hundred
thousand plus he's gonna be kicking it
yeah so you got a good you got a bright
future dude just be you know what I'm
telling you to do is the a way that has
very little to no risk and uh you're in
control of your life and you don't take
uh penalty steps backwards and get the
opportunity to start over
which by the way that's something worth
talking about for a minute and it works
in your career it works with your money
um
the thing that they're number one the
path to the gleaming mountain of success
is not a straight line
okay it's an ebb and flow there's a
little little uh tide goes in Todd goes
out in the process and the gleaming
mountain of success is actually a pile
of your failures
that you're standing on the things
you've learned the hard way everyone I
know that is a household name brand name
in any part of the world whether it's a
pastor that everybody in America knows
who that Pastor is or got a huge
Ministry or whether it's an author
that's done multiple number one
bestsellers or whether it's a business
person or a sports person or whatever it
is every time I run music people the
people that are inordinately successful
are colossal failures yeah so the the
the gleaming mountain of success is a
pile of mistakes now what they don't do
what they do in John Maxwell our friend
talks about this he wrote a book years
ago called failing forward they don't
make fatal mistakes they don't make
mistakes that set you back so far
there's tiny mistakes for course
correction yeah
and
the thing that keeps people from
becoming wealthy is a they don't apply
themselves to a simple set of principles
and B by not applying themselves to that
simple simple set of principles they
fall for these get rich quick crap and
they they have these tremendous setbacks
yeah you know I went and bought 10
houses and put them on Airbnb only to
find out the and leverage all of them to
their eyeballs only to find out that
Airbnb is now illegal in two of those
cities and only to find out that Airbnb
in the rest of the cities is completely
flooded and I can't keep them full and
so I'm not making any money and the guy
on Tick Tock lied to me yeah because he
didn't know what the flip he's talking
about that's right he didn't mean to lie
to me or maybe he did mean to lie to me
I don't know either way you lied to me I
got bad information and now you're
getting ready to get foreclosed on and
you're going to lose a portfolio of 10
properties and you're gonna go bankrupt
all because you were stupid yeah and
I've been stupid like that I did that
exact thing I had to start completely
over I'm so stupid I've been a
millionaire twice
right you know and so I I didn't just do
it once and it's a lot easier if you're
an atom situation just do it once that's
right here's what people Overlook Dave
about what you're saying greatness is a
process
you don't get to Greatness any of the
fields you mentioned without a process
you look at athletes you look at coaches
you look at Artists Craftsmen true
Craftsmen there's a process and what
they focus on is the little things the
fundamentals the process of trying the
process of failing to your point it's
not fatal they're going to learn from it
and what you learn when you have the
discipline to do the little things the
fundamentals to embrace the process
here's what happens you begin to hate
losing so very much that you will go the
extra mile to actually win and with this
Tick Tock generation and Instagram and
these get rich quick schemes it removes
the process the reason the baby steps
have worked for people
is because it's a process it doesn't
happen overnight but it does happen yeah
that's what successful people get they
embrace the process and I thought about
it but I was hanging out with this
comedian guy the other day that's got a
big Netflix special yeah and um did you
know you don't just go to a Netflix
special yeah no that you take all those
jokes you go into small clubs and test
them yeah yeah and get brutalized and
then they get brutalized on the exactly
he said it's harsh yeah but he said
before I get on there everything I know
everything I do on there I already know
works that's it exactly I've had course
Corrections interesting this is the
Ramsey Show
foreign
[Music]
well you've all played the telephone
game the first person Whispers a message
to the second person who Whispers it to
the third and so on around the table
until the original message has
completely changed multiply that
confusion by a hundred if you run a
business with different software systems
that don't talk to each other that's why
there's netsuite by Oracle in the early
days of Ramsay we were using different
systems for all of our business units we
needed one single source for accurate
data netsuite was the software we used
to optimize and take us to the next
level netsuite gave us the visibility
into all of our numbers so that we could
communicate across departments and plan
ahead better and as we grew it scaled
with us next week worked for Ramsey and
it will make a difference for your
business too join the more than thirty
four thousand customers who trust
netsuite to help make them smarter and
make better decisions and level up their
operations to learn more get a free
product tour at netsuite.com Ramsay
that's netsuite.com Ramsey
[Music]
thank you
Ken Coleman Ramsey personality is my
co-host today open phones at triple
eight eight two five five two two five
guys we need your help if you'd like to
help I can tell you how uh subscribe to
the show if and a follow or whatever it
is I mean whether it's YouTube or it's a
podcast or it's you know I don't Spotify
video Whatever It Is Twitter video
wherever it is subscribe to it follow us
that helps a lot leave a five star
review if they've got that opportunity
that helps a lot and
um a share it some of these Services
have a share button other times you just
tell people or you clip the link and you
send the link uh to somebody I was
listening to Craig groeschel's podcast
my buddy's podcast this week and uh it
was really good I sent him a note
personally it was just a outrageous uh
what do you call it um uh
well hours it was talking about being
outrageous with your with your goals
yeah I was just it was powerful and so I
clipped the link to it sent it to all
the on my leaders here and I'm like hey
this is inspiring watch this so you can
do that for us this show helped me this
did send it to somebody tell people
about it we we know you're doing that
because our numbers are way up and we
appreciate you thank you very much
Brittany is in California hi Brittany
welcome to the Ramsey Show
hi Dave hi Ken thanks for taking my call
sure hi what's up
okay so my husband and I have some
single stocks we are just finishing up
spu and we are in baby chef uh almost
done with baby step two going into step
three and we live in Southern California
and
um we are trying to figure out if we
should move the single stocks to mutual
funds or use it for a future down
payment the only catchers we don't
currently want to be homeowners
um my husband just took the debt clear
assessment thank you Ken and he's
thinking about switching jobs okay all
right so how long do you think it's
going to be before you buy a house if
you were to guess
[Music]
okay
all right
um I would cash out the stocks and put
them in mutual funds
and let them sit there as a how as a
house fund
okay okay get with a smart Vester Pro
pick something conservative that's not
super volatile and let it just sit there
and grow for five to eight years and
you'll be adding to that as you go along
as your down payment fund that's what
this is okay and then um and then just
you know make sure baby step three is
finished of course uh before you do that
and then but as soon as baby steps three
is finished whatever's left put that in
mutual funds towards your baby step
three B but your three B is going to be
hanging out a while and you're gonna go
on to four and start putting 15 of your
income into retirement yeah you're right
on track how much is in the stock
um a little over three hundred and
seventy thousand dollars good Lord
did you say you were still in baby step
two almost to go into three
yeah we'll be done next month yeah I
will catch some of that out already and
paid off all that debt but that's okay
you're there now yeah make sure your
emergency fund comes out of that before
you move it and then move it all over
into mutual funds yeah where'd you get
this stock
um it was is my husband it was basically
given to him when he was younger and his
name and kind of like an early
inheritance I guess yeah you're probably
going to have some
um some taxes on this too so you need to
get some tax advice and figure out
exactly what that's going to be but I'm
going to move it into mutual funds to
stabilize it and let it grow and that's
your house purchase fund when you do get
ready to buy a home not sure why you're
waiting five years to buy a house but I
get his career stabilized I wouldn't
wait eight years don't know that you
need to wait five years but uh 300 000
go a long way even in Anaheim California
so um yeah but you decide how you want
to do that hey thanks for the call open
phones at triple eight eight two five
five two two five Scots in Minneapolis
hi Scott how are you
good and yourself better than I deserve
how can I help
uh so let's see a little bit of a back
story I'm trying to help my wife help
her in her parents
um we're in her 50s they're in their
late 80s they have zero debt they've
owned a home for probably 40 years
um we uh her father-in-law has dementia
her dad has dementia so we're helping
the mom financially we want to make sure
that we know where all the money's
coming from because money's not talked
about openly
um and my wife is an only child and so
my financial advisor said hey ask for a
copy of their taxes and you can make
sure that there's nothing up there
hiding somewhere so we did everything
looked fine we know where their money's
coming in from but we also notice that
they have a reverse mortgage oh God
which surprised us because they'd never
they have all the money they need
they've never had anybody problems
um and they don't live extravagantly at
all so how old is the reverse mortgage
do you have any idea
so I
I taken out last January
and my wife concluded well that kind of
makes sense because maybe her mom is
looking for a potentially long-term care
options for the dad
but she actually did a little more
snooping she gets us in every other
weekend
last weekend and found the original
documentation and found out that it was
actually take out 20 years ago
and they were paying around five
thousand dollars a year in interest
based on last year's taxes which now I
can see is going to ten thousand dollars
a year because the interest rates
from what I can tell
I there were so many numbers it was a
little difficult for me to understand
but from what I can tell they're not
using any of the money I think they're
just painting basically I think they're
using it just like a home equity loan
but I don't know for sure and because
finances aren't openly discussed we're
trying to gather as much information
before we approach the subject with them
like what are their options if there
even are any options
well I don't know what you've got so I
don't know what your options are because
you don't know what you've got here so
other than them well I can tell you but
I mean they max out at 65 loan to value
so the most they owe on the house is 65
of its then value
the 20 years which the numbers make
sense there was a number in there of
like 197 000 always on a lake it's
probably worth roughly half a million so
that makes sense and then they quit
getting checks now they just have a debt
accruing interest sitting there
if they ever even got a single check I'm
not even sure that happened well the
checks had to come I mean that's the
only way the debt gets unblies
a reverse mortgage as you receive
payments and the balance goes up
it's the reverse of a regular mortgage
where you pay payments and the balance
goes down
yes so they've been receiving payments
for 20 years
okay up until it got to 197 and then cut
off
and then if it has cut off and I guess
it has
um and then it just starts accruing
interest and they get no more payments
so somewhere in the last 20 years
there's 200 Grand income
yeah okay and so the um we would see
that as income in their tax statement if
they were still no it's not taxable
oh got it it's it's borrow when you
borrow money you don't pay taxes on
borrowed money
okay if you go take out a loan from the
bank for ten thousand dollars they don't
charge you you know ten thousand dollars
a show up on your income tax right sure
this doesn't show up the only thing they
show up on their income taxes if they're
deducting the interest that they're now
paying and that would be if they're
doing a long-form income tax and not
doing standard deduction which they are
I mean these I thought why I sincere I
saw the statement which did you see
interest on there if you see interest
paid on that income tax statement then
they this this thing is ended and
they're having to pay the interest to
maintain it okay and the only way you
can get out of it is to sell the home
pay it back yeah you gotta you gotta
refinance and put it in a regular
mortgage which might not be a bad idea
probably because probably you're going
to find the interest rates High
well I I didn't know so you can re do
you can treat this like a normal life
they owe 200 000 on this they can pay it
off
okay I that I didn't know just go get a
200 000 loan at you know
15-year at uh six percent because
they're probably being charged 10 or 12.
yeah these reverse mortgages are the
worst thing on the planet they're just
ain't they're just horrible
horrible product and here's why now you
got 82 year old that's up a creek
because
some actor from another generation that
was on
the news channel telling you you needed
to borrow on your house
20 years ago when they were 62. this is
the Ramsey Show
[Music]
hey Dr John deloney here I'm a huge fan
of both meditation and prayer and good
mental health includes slowing down
gaining control of your thoughts and
plugging into something bigger than you
and Halo makes it easy to start a daily
practice of meditation prayer and
finding peace Hollow is the number one
Bible app in the world and you can
tailor content towards your faith
tradition from scripture readings and
prayers to meditation and journaling
hallow makes it easy to practice prayer
meditate and build a deeper more
meaningful spiritual life and ReDiscover
true peace go to hollow.com Ramsay today
to get three months of hallow for free
that's hallow.com Ramsay
[Music]
Ken Coleman Ramsay personality is my
co-host today open phones at triple
eight eight two five five two two five
you guys have known how bad the economy
is and you've known how bad inflation is
and you know how horrible the stock
market is right
or maybe you didn't
I just pulled it up for the fun of it a
minute ago the S P 500 which is the most
accurate measure of the New York Stock
Exchange
if you put money in 12 months ago today
one year ago today
uh and then left it alone until today
you would have made a
16.2 percent rate of return in the last
12 months
interesting now here's what I did it
Dove after the midterm elections
the stock market did not like the
results of the midterm elections
and it went way down and then it's just
gradually
come up a little bit of time every month
every day every week just kind of
chugging along and it passed
the old high and passed where we were 12
months ago at this time and
um now you're sitting on a 16 rate of
return no one talks about that do they
did you hear anybody say you could have
made 16 of on your money in the last 12
months and that's with an S P 500 which
is not sexy at all I mean that's about
boring as it gets yeah very interesting
and been on a very nice run by the way
this summer yeah very nice run but
nothing nothing spectacular
let's just bump it along but going up up
and to the right up and to the right
Melanie is in Washington DC hi Melanie
how are you
I'm doing well thank you for taking my
call sure what's up
my question is if it's a wise decision
for me to sell my home
and purchase my daughter's home and move
in and live with her she's currently
going through a divorce and she doesn't
have the finances to
buy out
um her spouse's portion of the home in
order to be able to afford it
um I'm sorry she's going through that
thank you
well I I think that would be a mistake
unless there's something more that
you're not telling me this sounds to me
like a mom whose heart is hurting for
her daughter and doesn't want her
daughter to have all the pain she's
having and you're trying to make some of
it go away
that's a nice motivation but this is not
a good plan
okay
so what we find out
go ahead sorry you go ahead so my
thought process was
um I'm looking to retire in a year or
two anyway and I was planning on kids in
a different state
so I was planning on moving out um
to live closer to her just because I've
lived here with all my other kids and
grandkids for a long time and he's
trying to have that chance to
be closer to them for a little while too
so my intention was of moving there in
another year or two anyway
but with the housing market I'm not
finding anything really affordable for
me as a single person retired
so I thought well why not buy her home
because that would help her out as well
but it doesn't sound like you think
that's a very good idea no because it's
a a temporary situation and you're
putting a permanent solution in she's
going to have to establish a sustainable
life
after the divorce for her own dignity
and for herself and
um
uh if she can't afford this house she
should not keep the house
and that's heartbreaking that's one more
heartbreak that goes with the Heartbreak
of a divorce and well that means the
kids have to move you know it's
heartbreaking but it's I tell you what's
more heartbreaking is a mom her that is
stressed out about money because she
keep kept Things based on the old life's
income that's not there anymore because
of the divorce and so I want her to have
a full reset and establish some ground
something solid to work from and if you
want to move to the area and be
emotional support to her that's fine but
you're leaving Washington DC which is an
expensive Market where does she live
she lives in a suburb of Salt Lake City
which is a cheaper Market than you're in
well a little bit I mean no it is
research on yeah no it is it is I don't
know where you researched but I mean
you're looking in a neighborhood there's
difference in the neighborhood you're
living in now so but Apples to Apples
neighborhood to Neighborhood Housing
price to housing price DC's more than
the cost of real estate's more than than
the Salt Lake for sure and I frequently
in both markets and know the real estate
market so I'm not just making this up
but yeah I I appreciate your sweetheart
and you want to be there for I would
rather you be there for emotionally
cheering her on but I want her to
scramble the eggs of her life and get a
new omelette get a new a new place to
start from a reset that's based on her
new income not her old income with her
husband
ex-husband now a new situation for her
children and let her come from Solid
Ground to rebuild her life because what
we run into Melanie is this and all the
years I've been doing this what normally
happens is this is kind of a I don't
know a stereotype almost
divorce happens dad moves out of the
house mom's income is lower than dads
and she tries to keep the house because
her mother's heart is to protect the
children's environment they don't have
to change schools they don't have to
change bedrooms they don't have to pack
up their stuff and go through more
trauma because they're already going
through the trauma of their parents
splitting up and Mama's trying to keep
them from feeling any more pain so she
tries to keep a house with less income
than than he makes and he used to be
there helping to pay that payment and
she generally Saddles herself with a
house she can't afford and instead of
creating the trauma for the children now
while it's going on and let them just
reset in a new place a little apartment
or whatever now they have to live with a
mom who's freaked out day in and day out
over money
and then she ends up losing the house or
having to give it away and after four
years of deep anxiety and stress and I
run into that like like thousands of
times in the last 30 years so my advice
is while the pain is there just go ahead
and get all the pain over with and do
the reset sell the stupid house she
can't afford the house sell it and let
her move into something that to reset
and built rebuild her life she got to
rebuild her career too that's the point
that I think you're making is that the
emotional support here for Melanie is
going to be great for her daughter and
that's enough this this daughter is
going to have to reset her life in
multiple ways and she needs to get out
on her own it's going to help her heal
by the way not in any way minimizing the
pain of this but getting out on your own
beginning to show that you're the mama
bear and I'd never bet against a mama
bear she can do it and it's going to
help the healing process and I think
restore her dignity Dave because the
dignity is robbed in a divorce one way
or the other it just is and this is a
case where again she she's going to end
up being better off by selling the house
and rebuilding yeah and don't don't try
to patch this together no it's just not
going to be good for her and it's not
good for you either because you're
saddled in there with one kid with all
of your Equity tied up in that house and
then you you can't make decisions that
are smart for either one of you yeah
it's just it creates a bad it's it's a
bad medicine so please don't do it it's
a sweet intent you're trying to help and
I appreciate that but don't this is this
is um it's it's it's a type of enabling
that you're doing here and I wouldn't do
it
open phones at triple eight eight two
five five two two five
divorces
um
it's um unbelievably
expensive financially emotionally
spiritually everything involved but in a
situation like that that's where you
really really feel it and um there's a
um it turns a a marriage into a business
transaction the splitting of the assets
and the liabilities right the allocating
of the mess and the settlement but then
also this
um The Grieving of what was supposed to
be this picture I had
jog Dr John delone talks about this
picture I had what old age was going to
look like now it's not going to look
like that what the next 10 years was
going to look like now it's not going to
look like that what walking her down the
aisle was going to look like my daughter
it's not going to look like that and uh
man that's a it's a process and in the
middle of that don't add Financial
stress to the equation because you kept
a car
or a house or something else stupid that
you couldn't afford this is the Ramsay
show
[Music]
oh
thank you for joining us America we're
glad you're here open phones at triple
eight eight two five five two two five
Ken Coleman Ramsey personality is my
co-host today
Angelique Angelica as I'm probably
saying that wrong Angelica Angelica
thank you I knew I was doing it wrong
Angelica's in Norfolk Virginia hi
Angelica how are you
right here
what in the world what a hillbilly well
you got hooked off of phonics for just a
second just for a second there huh
that's fine that's why I have Ken
Coleman here that's right 757 shout out
what's up
so I have a couple of questions
um one my husband is active duty
military and he recently got orders to
Spain
we will be leaving the states about this
time next year
so
we have
um quite a bit of money in savings and
we're trying to figure out the best way
to do that um knowing that we're not
going to be here
do we do a written you know do we do an
investment property do we put it in
mutual funds like we're trying to figure
out the best way to make our money work
for us rather than it just sitting in a
savings account Absolutely I'll just put
in mutual funds okay sit down with a
smartvester pro go to
ramsaysolutions.com click smartvestor
get your financial advisor that's got
the heart of a teacher tell them what
your goals are and they can help you
select some funds that um you know they
can give you good rates of return but
even if you just invested it in a
no-brain investment which would be an S
P 500 as I was saying a little bit
earlier you know it's up to 16 percent
year over year so
um you know that that's that kind you
want to park it there or not in four
percent or three percent or whatever
right
yeah okay so you wouldn't recommend
doing like even like the smallest like
rental no no no no no no long distance
landlording from Spain is a good way to
get in a mess
and that's kind of what we thought too
um it's just you know like I said and
then we're so kind of give you a little
bit of backstory
um just a very brief one
um we sold our house in Pensacola when
we moved here
um because renting didn't make sense
there either
um so we have all of our debts paid off
and everything like that so like I said
we have about 120 sitting there right
just kind of hanging out
um so how much would you suggest because
like I said we have our retirement put
away we have everything pretty much
taken care of good
um and that segues me into my second
question we are expecting to well we're
scheduled to have our first child on
Friday yay
yeah so
um we want to start planning for his
future we don't know if like obviously
it's very early
um never too early but I don't know how
much we should start way too much things
to do is to put 15 of your income away
for retirement start doing something to
start doing something for kids college
okay and make sure you have an emergency
fund of three to six months of expenses
do you have the emergency fund not
counting this hundred and twenty yes yes
we do all right when you sit down with a
smart investor Pro if you want to take
10 and throw it into a 529 for the new
baby you have to get a Social Security
number before you can do that but that
doesn't take that long okay and uh but
then you you know just start open a 529
for the baby throw 10 grand in you're
almost done for college if you do that
yeah because 10 grand by the time
they're 18 will grow to almost enough
but you'll add some in the years as you
go along and then you got 110 in there
now uh and then you're going to Spain
how much longer is he going to be in the
military
well if you're investing at an average
of 10 percent it will your lump sum will
double every seven
so seven years from now 110 would be
220.
okay okay and seven years later 220
would be 440. right so that's that's the
kind of curve you're on with this if you
don't add anything to it for purchasing
the next property but thank you for your
service both of you and congratulations
on the new baby that's fun yeah and it's
fun to see a story like this from our
military men and women who have been so
wise I mean they are in terrific
Financial shape been very disciplined
and and the fruits of it now here they
are starting a family in really good
shape yeah and really and you know the
Adventure Continues here we go to Spain
yeah right not a bad place to be
stationed yeah Patrick's with us in
Phoenix hi Patrick welcome to the Ramsay
show
hey Dave thanks for taking my call sure
what's up
so I am 20 years old and about two years
ago I moved to Phoenix Arizona to start
my own business selling furniture
uh I was straight out of high school and
just like super young and I moved in
with my aunt and uncle
uh so it's been two years later now I
saved about 40 000 in cash uh I have
like another 30 Grand in crypto
and I'm just wondering if it's a good
time to move out
okay how long have you been listening to
us
uh probably three or four years now I
actually met you in person all the time
okay
well are you going to take my advice
this time because you didn't on the
crypto
yeah see
how are you
yeah okay all right cash out the crypto
move out
get your life started okay you got 70
grand you're 20 years old you're kicking
butt but get get the money out of there
while you still got it because it's
gonna evaporate if you don't
and um okay yeah and then we're sitting
on 70 grand and you're making obviously
making some money what kind of money
you're making
uh I'll probably do about 100 Grand this
year wow what does selling furniture
look like what is that business model
picking it up clean it up and then take
really good pictures and sell it
give me an idea of a margin on something
you've done recently what you bought it
for versus what you sold it for
so recently I bought an outdoor
sectional for five hundred dollars I pay
someone 200 to fix it up for me and then
a couple days ago I sold it for 26.50
700 in cost and he flipped it for 2600
bucks somebody's outdoor sectional that
just probably needed to be scrubbed
right
yeah right
where are you getting where are you
doing this work because you're living
with your aunt and uncle they're you're
not doing it in their garage are you
yes I actually just got uh two Warehouse
spaces I guess you did okay dude you're
a stud that is awesome I absolutely love
it you're a player yep you're a player
well done well done yeah in another hour
we read a question about what we thought
about Universal income uh you know a
stipend for people that won't work and
then you got a 20 year old with a high
school education that's making a hundred
grand flipping used furniture
and some of you are standing around with
your finger in your ear
unbelievable American dream is alive and
well what a country yeah there it is
there it is
again folks wow yeah that's great what a
great guy I love you Patrick Yeah sell
the stupid crypto move out on your own
you get your life you're doing great
proud of you well done
that is so great an outdoor sectional
you know 26 yeah I mean 2 600 bucks is
cheap for I mean that's a good that's a
good deal and oh my gosh that's great
yeah I can just see him driving along
with something sitting on the curb
somebody's throwing it out the state can
I have that yeah you know and put the
leg back on it and this is an example by
the way of
what it means to live in a very wealthy
country
people are throwing away essentially a
nice sectional he turns around and makes
really good cash on it he's taking what
other people are thinking is trash or
they're on they're moving on to the next
thing I gotta finance my outdoor section
I'll get something new he's making a
real money it's a really interesting
commentary on where we are at in America
today but the opportunity to make
something of yourself is still there you
know what else I think about when I hear
somebody like Patrick show up his mom
and dad did a great they did they did
that's right they taught him to work
yeah they taught him how to work a
margin you know somebody did I mean
you're not born with that no you know no
yeah I've been to the hospital they
always say you know it's a boy it's a
girl they don't say it's an entrepreneur
yeah so somebody taught him that you
know that that you know wow here's
something else too this is special young
man
but a lot of culture and Society will
look down on him because he didn't go to
college he's laughing all the way to the
bank yeah he's two warehouses 250 000
and I got a master's degree in social
work and I make 38 000 at the state
right and I'm in debt up to my eyeballs
yeah that's that's just contemporary oh
my gosh
this is the Ramsay show
[Applause]
[Music]
oh
Dave here you can find all of our shows
with the Ramsay Network app on your
smartphone it's the only place to listen
to the entire back catalog of episodes
download the Ramsay Network app in your
favorite app store today
[Music]
live from the headquarters of Ramsay
Solutions broadcasting from the PODS
moving in storage Studios it's the
Ramsay show where we help people
build wealth do work that they love and
create actual amazing relationships open
phones this hour Ken Coleman host of the
Ken Coleman show Ramsay personality
number one best-selling author of the
book paycheck to purpose talking about
careers jobs and how you make money with
your life he is my co-host today so you
got questions about that jump in again
the phone number triple eight eight two
five five two two five speaking of
Ramsay personalities student loans are
happening
student loan problems are happening your
student loan you're going to start
paying on it again shortly I hope you're
ready so Jade watch all Ramsay
personalities hosting a student loan
webinar limited space
totally free so she's going to talk to
you about how to get ready for starting
back up and all the issues around the
whole student loan crisis debacle epic
failure or whatever whatever adjective
you want to use for it she'll help you
with it Jade warshaw totally free
there's just a handful of slots left for
this free webinar go to
fpu.com
student loan and it's a free webinar
with Jade warshaw on student loans
fpu.com
student loan Yesenia is next in Lubbock
Texas kicking off this hour hi Yesenia
how are you
I'm good how are you Dave better than we
deserve what's up
so um my husband has decided that we
should move up to Oregon Because he
believes the cost of living is lower and
we'd be able to get a better start we
currently do not have credit on a home
or anything like that so we've been
renting for the past three years
and so we're looking to buy a
fixer-upper home that are in my in-laws
would help us get and then you know
start paying off and such and it's about
40 40K and then to remodel and such we'd
invest about 60 possibly and currently
we owe about 10 in student loans and we
have 3 000 in savings that we could use
so considering we'd be moving about 1500
miles away we may need that to use to
move away or we may you know so paying
off our student loans right now I'm not
sure if that would be the wisest
decision and then we also have a about
30 000 in our car loan
good Lord that we just took out
there's a lot going on in this call what
uh what's your household income
it's about 40 to 60k a year but my
husband has potential to make more
because he has his CDL for Trucking
and his family
is an organ
yes
okay
uh so so you're asking me what
so what would you recommend do you think
it would be a wise thing to to move in
this current situation that we're in and
with our savings nope
you guys aren't going to like me and
you're probably not going to do what I
tell you to do but you're gonna wish you
did uh you don't need to buy a fixer-up
upper when you're broke people
it's going to cause you problems
he's got this dream in his head that if
he can just get closer to family this is
all going to work out cost of living in
Oregon and Lubbock Texas is not any
different that's absolute BS
you're not you don't live in a high cost
of living area darling
he found his daddy or his mom I found a
fixer-upper and he's got the bug to move
back home that's where how all this was
going well he's dreaming all this up
while he's around while he's driving
truck
he's sitting there thinking about it all
day while he's grinding gears so no it's
I got to tell you please don't do this
it's going to be a mess
and so what would I do if I were in your
shoes I'd work like six jobs I'd sell a
stupid car you just bought get you a car
you can afford that's absolutely
ridiculous purchase
and then I'd get those debts paid off
and once the debts were paid off I'd
pile up some money and then if you want
to make a move make a move and pay cash
for the little Fixer-Upper or go up
there and rent until you can pay cash
for the little fixer upper
but there is no cost of living move from
Lubbock to Oregon
all right how long have you been are you
working and how long has he been driving
the truck with the CDL what's going on
there
he's been Trucking about a year and I
have my degree in in biology so I could
use that to teach or to continue my
education my goal is to be to go and be
an EMT for the meantime so that I'm
generating income
when are you doing that
EMT would be in about would be at in
January why
this is July when the program would
start
what are you going to do between now and
then
or I can look to start in September
that's what I am you got to be working
you guys can knock this out ten thousand
dollars in student loan debt you can
knock that out quickly what's the car
worth
the car I think it's worth about what we
paid I think it was worth like two to
three thousand more than what we paid
yeah get out of that now please get out
of that
it was a huge mistake
is that not just does that not just have
red lights on top of it flashing at you
going
error error error
I definitely had lost a lot of sleep
over the debt for sure yeah yeah and
then we just added a big old pile to it
just for the fun of it because we wanted
to go buy a car so when you slow down
and develop
step-by-step plans to clear debt build
cash then move then build cash before we
buy
okay so you think it'd be a very foolish
decision to move across the country
almost 100 sure
I'm 100 sure it'd be very foolish for
you to move across the country the way
you just described it to me
absolutely I kind of thought it was a
bit far-fetched but
um there are plenty of really good job
opportunities down here my husband would
just not be home at all so that's kind
of why I've been a stay-at-home mom for
the past year and a half and also
because of the cost of child care for me
to be a biology teacher which is all I
have right now so what's keeping him
what's keeping him from getting that
better job just that it's not ideal for
the family
I think so but I really pray he would
just have the wisdom to take that step
I've tried telling him that that's what
husbands have to do it's the next step
for them to be providing and taking care
of the family and it's not always
comfortable I would love for him to be
home but that's not where we're at
financially or with you know starting
out our new lives and well what if it's
a season at home what if it's a season
for a period of time if it takes you
guys sell a car if it takes you guys a
year to get your finances straightened
up so you can move then all of you go to
work and let's get moving that's right
everybody pays a price let's get this
moving and then then head off to Oregon
I'm not mad at Oregon okay you can go uh
but you know he's got this all dreamed
up that he's gonna you know what we have
is a mess and then let's go ahead and
buy a house that's a mess
and add a mess to a mess
that that's just you're just you're
signing up for Terror no thank you the
harder he works Yesenia the faster you
get to Oregon that would be the vision I
would try to cast with him you know
right after we sold the car oh yeah did
I mention you need to sell that car I
hope I was clear about that
this is the Ramsay show
[Music]
[Applause]
thank you
[Music]
hey guys being free to make your own
medical decisions is a big deal these
days Christian Healthcare Ministries
gives members the freedom to choose the
doctors and providers they want without
the frustration of worrying about
networks and with no waiting period to
join it's a membership-based non-profit
Ministry where hundreds of thousands of
Christians share funds to pay for and
pray for each other's medical bills for
over 40 years chm has helped families
living across all 50 states so cfchm
could be right for your family check out
more today at
chministries.org budget
foreign
[Music]
Coleman Ramsay personality is my co-host
today we appreciate you being with us
Sam St Paul Minnesota Hi Sam how are you
good gentlemen thank you so much for all
you do and thank you for taking my call
certainly how can we help
yeah so I have a little bit of a generic
question here in terms of negotiating uh
salary for a promotion uh internal to my
own my own company basically they create
a new position for me to move up to a
managerial role and um instead of
talking directly to my boss off the bat
how I'm being asked to talk to an HR
representative just asking what my
preferred salary would be they have a
posted range
um which is good but I'm kind of curious
how you if you have any suggestions on
how you approach that with the folks
that you've been working with for a long
time and will continue to work with and
forward going forward
um to maximize my salary and also keep
relationships good and positive
what's the range yeah that's what I'm
curious about yeah so I currently make
120 the new range is 135 to 175.
posted publicly
and I'm exceed all the criteria because
the job description was basically my
resume cut and pasted and put on a job
on a job board
this is Corporate America how long
you've been with them yeah
uh four years
there's no there's no particular formula
for this answer uh what what I would do
I'm interested to know what Dave I want
Dave to come at this from the from the
CEO the the leader side I'll come at it
from what I hear and what I read out
there in the marketplace but looking at
this range
um you've you've there this is going to
come down to what I believe is the gut
test
if you believe
that you can say I believe based on my
experience
uh my skill set you got to look at the
open market too not just the way that
this job is posted you got to go out
there and do your homework and you can
do it and you can find out okay based on
my skill set and experience do I feel
like out in the out in the marketplace
that I could command the 175 let's call
that that's the top end of this deal uh
then then the gut needs to reveal that
if you've got that and you feel like you
can say hey I think I can command this I
think if I look at the market I'd like
to see it at the high end but you're not
demanding it you're answering their
question if they've asked you from an HR
perspective what would you like to make
you can say I'd like to make this and
it's based on skill experience matching
up in the marketplace that I'm at the
high end of this range but if you can't
validate that I would never ask for it
because I just think that that it's
never going to end well because I'm
assuming they've done their homework and
they know where you fit in the range as
well that'd be my answer and how I would
handle it personally I normally would
until they used your resume to cut and
paste the job post
that is The X Factor yeah and so in this
case uh are you gonna be in person Sam
with the HR person
no they're in a different state than our
location so this is by email or
something this was just an email with
about five questions in it and that's
the first time salaries come up okay and
so uh I guess I don't I don't know I
mean this environment sounds very uh
formal to me uh so I don't know that my
response will work but um my my tendency
would be to put like a bunch of smiley
faces and go hey guys let's be real this
job posting is my resume reposted which
means you guys intend to do some 175 and
I'll be happy with that
yeah I like that with some smiley faces
and just you know just tell just because
that's exactly what they did
and just saying it out loud and going
that's my justification for 175.
because that's what you all think it's
worth thank you and we appreciate it you
guys are awesome wink wink Smile Smile
whatever I don't know well what's your
Instagram sunglasses I don't know I mean
whatever whatever Emoji you want to use
there but I I would try to lighten this
up a little bit and just say out loud
what's really going on because I think
that's your best leverage to get the 175
and I'd go for it
okay
do you think um unless these guys are
such tight butts that they're gonna get
all twisted up because you tried to have
a joke about it I mean my God
yeah you you've got uh you've got a
little bit of trepidation anxiety on you
for real what's it coming from what are
you worried about
well I mean I'm relatively you know
young and not that that matters I you
know I like you said I checked the boxes
that they're looking for
um but I'm wondering if you'd ever if if
uh so my my the direct hire manager is
my current manager and uh we have a
wonderful open relationship and very you
know open and honest and and that's how
it's been over the past you know four
years ever since I came on board are you
still gonna be working for him
and say if I put that on this HR form is
that going to be okay would you Mentor
me and tell me what to do
there's a difference between asking and
demanding yeah they gave you the range
and they asked you your opinion yeah so
say I want the 175. I'm just happy to be
here but it looks to me like you guys
use my resume for this job posting and I
thank you for that and I'm excited about
this role and 175 would just be awesome
thank you very much yeah and see ask
your Mentor if uh you're up line if he
thinks that that's gonna if that's gonna
cause you to be a jury you know you
don't want to look like a jerk we're not
trying to be sarcastic or or crazy or
something but I mean it's it's just kind
of like calling out what's really going
on and and that takes all the um smoke
and mirrors all the pressure out of the
room it lets the air out of the balloon
you know he's in a situation where he
can do the calculated ask which is what
I was walking through versus a crazy ask
this is not a crazy ass to ask for the
175. so they can always come back at you
with something but I tell you this if
you say 155 if they're going to come
back with something they've already
lowered it so that's why I go home
they're not gonna go I don't think so
you know we think 175 right if you don't
so I'm going to ask for it for sure I
just got to figure out how I'm gonna ask
for it that's right but I'm going for
the whole puppy in this case you know no
question about it
oh man why is communication so hard in
companies it's just people man open
phone's a triple eight eight two five
five two two five Tom is in DC hey Tom
welcome to the Ramsay show what's up
yes hello thanks for taking my call
um just a little background I'm very
familiar with your stuff I actually used
to teach it thank you so I kind of know
the answers you're going to tell me but
um maybe I have a little bit of
different Dynamics maybe some just
calling for clarification so long story
short I inherited some money from my
brother
um so I am the sole I'm the sole heir to
all this and I've done all the leg work
and have proper paperwork and all that
stuff so long story short there is about
380 000 in total
um half will be from sale of house half
will be 401ks and a little bit of life
insurance and stuff like that so my
question is twofold
um one is I'm being told that
these 401ks I will be taxed on them
because I was never labeled as a
beneficiary
properly within the 401K even if you
were there would be an income tax on
them yeah it's not an inheritance tax
it's an income tax but yeah
so it'll throw me in a different tax
bracket correct
I mean
your your tax you know
um it's an inherited 401K whether you're
the beneficiary or not and um you have
to clear it in 10 years
so you don't have to do it all at once
but you got to do a tenth a year
a tenth a year yeah got it how much is
in the 401K
um probably about 195 all said between
two of them okay all right and so if
your tax is 50K
I'd be tempted to just cash out enough
of it just cash it out and pay the 50k
and not worry about it
and just be done yeah I kind of agree
yeah okay I don't think I screw around
it's not that much and you've got the
liquidity to do it I'd sit down with
your tax professional make sure that
calculation is accurate and withhold
that much and then just roll it into
wherever you are in your baby steps but
very well that's that puts you in a
great situation I'm sorry for your bro
you lost your brother bro man that's
that's sad but um yeah you just plow
your way through the details which is
what you're doing so very well very well
played this is the Ramsay show
[Music]
[Applause]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
Coleman Ramsey personality is my co-host
this hour I'm Dave Ramsey your host if
you haven't heard we will be in Chicago
doing the smart conference and we is all
the Ramsey personalities me Rachel Dr
John deloney Jade warshaw George
Campbell and Ken Goldman all day long
will be there September 15 and 16th the
Platinum tickets are all sold out but
there are some General Admissions left
at 99 if you want to be there in Chicago
Chicago's a cool trip too come on up
hang out with us if you're especially in
the Chicagoland area you can get your
tickets at Live Events tab at
ramseysolutions.com we'd love to have
you on the debt free stage in the lobby
of Ramsey Solutions Ryan and Kate are
with us hey guys how are you hey Dave
thanks for having us absolutely welcome
where do you all live Denver Colorado oh
welcome to Nashville and how much data
have you paid off we paid off seventy
thousand dollars in 34 months yay and
your range of income during that time
range of income was anywhere from thirty
five thousand to sixty seven thousand
very cool very cool and what kind of
debt was the seventy uh it was mainly it
was all me uh so it was mainly credit
card debt and a bunch of student loan
debt
okay all right how much of the 70 was
student loans about 55 yes okay and 15
in credit cards okay cool very cool very
cool all right what do you all do for a
living I'm a physical therapist
assistant and I'm in franchise
development all right very good so uh 34
months 70 grand and it's all Ryan's
fault we've established that
so tell me the story how did you guys
get plugged into Ramsey and decide to
pay off your debt and do it in three
years well I met my wife
um in college at Texas Tech and we ended
up meeting in the marching band she was
plugged into FPU through her family and
we ended up doing it because of that I I
saw you on the Fox Business channel so I
ended up really uh being plugged in and
listening to what she wanted me to do so
it worked out really well but I have
been well indoctrinated into the system
so my parents actually took FPU about
mid-2000s so I'm the Dave Ramsey kid I
have had the envelope System since I was
eight yeah we prefer to call them
Financial Peace kids you're your parents
kid okay yeah all right
well done y'all great job very cool
congratulations so yeah you come in all
indoctrinated uh that's a pretty strong
cult-like word but okay yeah all right
good and uh Ryan says okay he's on a
he's on Fox Business so we're gonna do
it right I like that yeah and here's
what I like you said I pretty much
listened to her and did what she wanted
me to do this was this was a guy who
knows uh the secret to a happy marriage
so you got on board pretty quickly but
the question is is what did you do to
get going were you gazelle right out of
the gate where did you kind of get along
slowly in it what did that look like for
you yeah so we started actually in May
of 2020 about two months before we got
married so we decided to have those
conversation to get that transition
going before all the ink was dried on
our certificate
um and even though with kovid going on
and everything in the chaos of the world
we really just decided that we were
going to do it regardless of what was
happening
yeah exactly so that's really what
happened and our Temple or dead snowball
started off really small but you know we
just kept pushing and kept going
[Music]
okay what you do to make the income go
up uh so we originally started as a
condominium a front desk person and a
server working every hour that we could
and then about a year into it we or I
upgraded jobs that doubled our income
nice so that really really helped yeah
really helped make it through school as
well yeah we actually six months in to
our journey my husband got into his last
round of schooling and we had a moment
of I don't know how we're going to do
this without getting another loan I
don't know and we had to sacrifice a
very generous wedding present that we
received to Kickstart the school Savings
and to pay
um wow what was it can you tell us uh it
was a gift it was about ten thousand it
was really generous and we were we
wanted to use it for the beginning of a
down payment of a house but um
you know sacrifices had to be made well
but you did because the way you get the
down payment for the house is he now has
a better income because he got the
degree yeah there you go I mean PT that
you're going to be you're gonna be okay
there yeah good stuff well done uh but
that's a hard decision yeah it hurt for
sure and the good news is you were
actually thinking about it both of you
know did you argue about that
um no not too much honestly we didn't
argue about the bigger stuff we argued
about the 30 here and there that were
unplanned on the Free Spirit she's the
nerd yeah okay so she so you went and
spent thirty dollars on something almost
lost your life yes yes sir yes sir you
can tell there's a little bit of trauma
there on her face when she mentions the
little thirty dollars here kill him I'm
gonna kill him I'm gonna kill him yeah
ten thousand dollars and then he goes
and does that I love it that's fun
that's good you guys are great that's
that's exactly how it works though I
mean you've got to be talking about it
you got to be talking through the
conflict
um you gotta cry about the sacrifice a
little bit and uh it hurts and you gotta
uh I mean that that this is how this
whole thing works because the people
that avoid all of that are the ones that
just go do whatever the flip they want
to do and then they spend the rest of
their life paying paying the man you
know and so you guys were very mature
you're looking long every one of your
decisions were long-term thinking yes
not short-term thinking yeah and that's
that's pretty amazing I mean well beyond
your years very very very well done so
uh Ryan I'm pretty sure your father and
mother-in-law are pretty happy they are
yes sir they are okay well who else was
cheering you guys on out shot the two of
you oh we had an amazing support system
we were supported on all sides both all
family members on both sides and friends
we talked to co-workers about it we
talked to anybody and anybody who would
listen anybody and everybody so we're
very thankful so quick shout out to the
McNeely McCullough and the Askew Brooks
family because
it was so helpful and we are so grateful
yeah any uh any haters in the group not
really most people were happy but some
people were confused but happy at the
same time they're like I don't know
how does I got married I got weird yeah
always a couple haters yeah yeah there's
always somebody that's okay that's part
of the program that's those motivate me
sometimes more than the encouragers so
yeah good for you guys well done very
well done all right now that you're
professionals you've paid off in 34
months with great sacrifice
seventy thousand dollars straight out of
school straight into marriage straight
into this debt snowball stuff what's the
key to getting out of debt when
somebody's listening they're watching
you right now you actually did it it's
not Theory so for me it's the free
spirit it's impulse control and having
discipline learning that discipline and
also trusting your partner
um and for you and since I'm a huge nerd
so I'm always going to say budget I mean
we had it was our main two will our main
weapon against it and we really I love
budgets I could talk about them all day
but then also having a reason why that's
big enough you know I had a few reasons
why but they vary day to day which one
was bigger than the lack of motivation I
guess yeah so very good I like that word
weapon on budgets I might use that it's
a weapon against Financial stupidity
yeah that's good I like it the Destroyer
it's good worker may have a cartoon
before this I see a lightsaber yeah
you're thinking Conan you know yeah this
is good yeah very good well done very
good stuff hey we've got the live and
give box for you the baby steps
millionaires book which is uh for sure
you're well on your way to that uh the
Financial Peace University which started
the whole thing for your parents and now
you can go through it as a young couple
or you can give it away if you've
already been through it that's fine
whatever it's the live and give that's
the whole idea Total Money Makeover book
you've been doing that so you'll give
that one away to somebody I'm sure and
be an encouragement to somebody you guys
Pay It Forward very very well done sharp
young couple you guys are very cool
heroes thank you Heroes I'm proud of you
very good stuff Ryan and Kate Denver
Colorado
seventy thousand dollars paid off in 34
months making 35 to 67
000 a year count it down let's hear a
debt free scream
three two one
three yeah
[Applause]
yeah I love it very cool very cool we
are seeing the generational effect now
yep uh more and more and more even some
third Generations but a lot of
Financial Peace babies out there yeah
and be careful how we name it yeah
that's exactly right the natural Peach
babies out there and uh very cool very
cool very neat this is the Ramsey Show
[Music]
foreign
our scripture of the day Ephesians 4
22-24 put off your old self which
belongs to your former manner of life
and is corrupt through deceitful desires
and to be renewed in the spirit of your
minds
and put on the new self created after
the likeness of God and true
righteousness and holiness
Andy Warhol said they always say time
changes things but you actually have to
change them yourself
it's true time doesn't change squat
that's right except wrinkles but yeah
other than that oh my gosh all right
Xander's with us in uh Norfolk Virginia
hi Xander how are you
hey Dave I'm good how about you better
than I deserve what's up
hey uh I just have a quick question
um
I'm 22 married and in the Navy out here
in Norfolk
and my mother-in-law she lives out in
Wisconsin
uh I met her daughter when I was up
there for basic training
she's a very sweet Christian lady who
never has any bad intentions but
her situation is she's disabled from a
car accident a couple of years ago
somebody hit her in a crosswalk
and um
I love her
and my wife loves her obviously but
uh we're afraid that she's
going to end up living with us
eventually
and we just don't want family members
living with us period not not
specifically her
but I I don't know I don't think she has
retirement because she just did like
housekeeping jobs before that
and she was a stay-at-home mom for a
little bit
but I don't I don't know what to do from
here and I I don't know how to talk to
her about it because she's very
sensitive
when it comes to things like this
where's where's Dad
not in the picture uh he he's just in
Arizona somewhere oh so they're divorced
yeah okay for how long
um quite a few years since my wife was a
pre-teen okay okay
all right and you guys have just gotten
married recently
uh yeah within the last um uh Year we're
hitting our one year in a month uh
congratulations and thank you for sure
thank you for serving your country and I
appreciate the um sense of love and the
sense of responsibility you have towards
her
um
uh
uh you're not in a place you can talk to
her about it
she can't she can't discuss this with
you
you haven't been here long enough
and it doesn't matter how smart you are
or how good your intentions are uh to
speak into people's money as a very
personal thing and
um and it requires a
uh
pretty in-depth relationship
and so I I think you don't worry about
it right now uh do you have any idea how
okay she's disabled you said permanently
she lives on disability right now she
lives with her mom and dad okay so how
much does she make in disability you
have any idea
a couple of grand a month probably right
I mean she's getting SSI from the
government is she getting any other
disability was there any settlement on
the car wreck
no there was a settlement but she's
working with somebody to renew her her
health insurance right now and they said
that she had to spend half of it because
she couldn't have a certain amount for
the health insurance and she only makes
about 900 a month
she had to spend half of the
okay she needs different advice on the
health insurance
that's what I tried to tell her but she
said that the lady works with this the
Social Security or whatever that for
sure she needs somebody different
I mean let's ask the IRS about our taxes
well that's a dumb butt idea you know
and that's what she's doing she's
talking to Social Security about
everything now you don't need to get
your financial advice from the Social
Security office they're not that bright
so no she needs to get outside of this
and get some other information your
daughter is going to have to talk your
daughter your wife is gonna her daughter
is gonna have to talk to her she's not
gonna listen to you man you've not been
on the game long enough
what should my wife say to her about
just she needs to get some outside
advice because when people start saying
you have to dumb down your money in
order to Simply get health insurance you
need different advice
okay okay so she she didn't get a lump
sum settlement she got a monthly
uh no the monthly is the uh the
disability that she gets it's about 900.
and then um the it was a lump sum of
like
10 or 20 000 it wasn't a lot
no it was happened
okay her disability ought to be more
than 900 bucks coming from Social
Security
yeah that's what I thought but I don't
know that much about the situation
because I don't like I don't like it
probably on personal stuff like that
yeah well it's not personal it's just I
think the government I I think there's
something missing here because it would
normally be more in the 2K range
so and she's living with her parents
she's living with her parents and that
that's what worries me is that when her
parents moved to move in with um uh my
wife's Aunt then I don't know what
happens to her yeah and she's trying to
move out here to Wisconsin but she keeps
hitting roadblocks with uh government
housing and whatnot she can't afford
anything what is the nature of her
disability what is her permanent
disability what happened to her
um she can't
stand for very long she can't move
around very fast
um
that I think that's all I know of okay
but her mind her mind is working fine so
can I how old is the lady
uh she's in her mid-40s okay there's a
book an old book called what color is my
parachute yeah yeah yeah and and you
talk about the four types of what we
were talking about the other day yeah so
what we have to do is we got to figure
out what our long-term prognosis is if
that's the long-term prognosis then
she's gonna have to do work that is
probably remote nature and it's going to
be computer and phone work or she can
use her mind and not working is not an
option yeah she has to work so the
question is is she good at people work
is she good at ideas work uh is she good
at process work those are three of the
four types of work she's not gonna be
able to work with things and be physical
and so if you can help her ideate and
we'll give you at the end of this call I
want to give you the get clear career
assessment which I want her to take and
this will create a very natural and fun
conversation with her daughter your wife
as we look to what are some jobs that
she can do that will allow her to make
some money to a dig out be sustain
herself long term because she can still
do work and and there's plenty of remote
work for that type of again customer
service work uh could be administrative
in nature so we got to figure out what
she's good at and what she enjoys so if
I'm your wife I'm your wife I'm saying
hey Mom
you're going to live another 40 years
yeah if I'm you I don't want to live 40
years on the government yeah it's not
gonna it's not enough and I don't want
to live 40 years in government housing I
want a better life than that and so if
I'm you I'm going to start thinking
about how I can make some money
stack some cash mom I mean I want you to
go get a career that you can do around
the particular challenges that you've
got with the book what color my
parachute is about all the people that
in spite of uh supposed disabilities go
out and make incredible incomes yeah and
um because they don't deter they don't
say all right I'm going to live on 900
bucks a month I mean I don't want to
live in poverty for 40 years yeah I'm
gonna find something to do I mean I'm
gonna paint something with my teeth I
mean I'm gonna do something my gosh how
do you feel about the daughter saying to
the mom and a loving and respectful way
hey we've got a boundary here we need to
make you aware of we don't want anybody
living with us and I just want to get
that out there I wouldn't do that
they've been married just a minute yeah
so too soon they're both worried they
both are hyper worried early in this
marriage I mean if they've been married
five years and it's going on maybe but I
I you know and if you're not careful
Xander is going to getting blamed for
this that is true and he's going to be
the evil step he's going to be the evil
evil son-in-law everything was good so
he come along you know I had everything
figured out and then he come along yeah
yeah so no sheep but you need your your
wife needs to talk to her mom and say
Mom I love you too much to watch you
live in poverty for 40 years we got to
work on your career and I got this
assessment from Ken Coleman and he'll
help you and he will do just that so
hang on we'll get that out to you that
puts us out of the Ramsey Show in the
books we'll be back with you before you
know it in the meantime remember there's
ultimately only one way to financial
peace and that's to walk daily with the
Prince of Peace Christ Jesus
[Music]
hey it's Ken if you like what you heard
in this episode and want to know more
about getting started on the Ramsey Baby
Steps go to ramsesolutions.com and click
on the get started button we'll help you
figure out the best next step for you
based on your specific situation again
that's ramseysolutions.com and click get
started
[Music]